good morning believe nation today's
message is living the present over to
you Tom Brady when I'm playing football
I appreciate it
I'm nowhere else I'm in the present
there's probably the best part about
best part about my life is that to be in
the present you talk about how do you
enjoy your life how do you find balance
right it's to live in the present you
play to live like a kid like why do kids
have so much fun because they just care
about what they're doing yeah and if we
thought about what we were doing all the
time you do that when you're on the
football field it's probably the only
place that I can really do that when I
really truly am my authentic self I mean
a lot of people see it my close close
friends do but when I'm on the football
field there's no it's just wrong
so what do you think I completely agree
with Tom Brady I feel like it is
important to live in the present for
three specific reasons the first one is
if you're living in the present you're
not dwelling on the past and everything
that you could have done to improve your
life or everything that you could have
changed the second one is if you're
living in the present you don't have any
expectations for the future and you
won't be disappointed with whatever life
throws at you you'll go into life with
an open mind and the third point is it's
pointless to live in the future because
you never know what life is gonna throw
at you so there's no use in fixating and
planning for things that you can't plan
and now you can't control I love it it's
this first time on YouTube that's great
my thoughts are it's about focus you
know when we are trying to do something
and we're thinking about something else
we're not we're not doing a good job
what we're doing that like we're trying
to film a video here for YouTube now if
I'm thinking about what am I getting for
dinner or think about my wife or all
right I'm not gonna bring it and so as
much as possible you want to try to stay
in that moment stay present because
you're gonna produce the best result
possible at whatever you're trying to do
so the question of the day today is what
can you guys do today to keep living in
the present I love it leave in the
comments below or during the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
we go